CES is a seemingly endless bonanza of
product of use everything from cars and
drones to headphones and televisions is
on display here and in mind boggling
quantities these are wired favorite
products drones aren't just toys anymore
if en can get it single passenger
carrying autonomous helicopter drone has
regulators it may usher in the age of
self flying cars mate speaking of robots
we couldn't get enough of segues
advanced personal robot which is the
most adorable rideable hoverboard
robotic Butler we've ever seen if you're
busy riding the robot Butler let French
security company mint at moes smart
outdoor camera keep an eye on the front
door you can tell the difference between
people and pets and can be set up to
blast a spotlight on intruder we love
Samsung's ultra portable featherweight
13 inch notebook nine new windows 10
just a tad heavier than the ipad pro a
surface pro 4 and should run for 10
hours on a charge
you're lugging a laptop around feels
like too much check out Carl Zeiss is
smart streamlined augmented reality
defenses which made us forget the
clunkiness of google glass the lenses
which aren't quite ready for market
should work in different frames from
stylish hipster detect out
televisions keep getting better than our
favorite this year was LG's LED g6 which
is both absurdly huge as being as 77
inches but also absurdly thin
no price yet but likely in the five
figures for this binge-watch worthy
piece of walking group CES went back to
the future to one of our favorites with
the return of film in the eve Behar
design kodak super 8 camera it's a
brilliant Mitch digital and analog for
budding oh tours and audio files rejoice
vinyl has a new home on the sony PS HX
500 turntable the six hundred dollar
record player is also a plug-and-play
preamp and has a USB out for
transferring those rare grooves to the
cloud